hello Patricia Arquette you don't really
need an introduction so I have that you
know I had many words to say but
actually you don't you have an NGO you
focus a lot of your energy on climate
change and women and a lot of people
here and a lot of people watching us
will not know the link between the two
why is that your focus yes
so my NGO is called give love org and we
do ecological sanitation in the
developing world a lot of people don't
think you know that sanitation really
crosses many sectors that impact women I
do women's rights I work on women's
rights in America I work on equal pay in
America and in the developing world I
work on improved sanitation and part of
the reason is because many women girls
drop out of school because they don't
have facilities go to the bathroom they
don't have places to deal with their
menstrual flow women don't have security
because they're being sexually assaulted
because they have to go to community
toilets many women say they can't even
go to the bathroom at night last our
last trip an elderly woman we piloted a
household pilot a toilet and she had it
and she said now I don't have to go
outside this is in the middle of an
manana in the middle of nowhere now I
don't have to go outside the stick fence
where I can get hit on the head and
raped at night and I'm looking at her
and thinking she's 70 years old when do
you get to stop worrying about being
raped
when does that day come so the crossover
between climate change and sanitation is
as we see climate change come we know
that women the majority of women say in
Africa 75 to 90 percent of the of the
Agriculture work is done by women and
they have to also collect the firewood
and the fuel for fire they also have to
collect the water as water dries up
these resources come further and further
away from them the lack of sanitation is
the number one pollutant to water so as
we look at climate change in having less
water we're going to also be looking at
the impact on the water sources we do
have so when women are gonna have to go
further and further and a lot of people
don't know that
the mega slums that we find all around
the world are built on flood plains and
intentionally there's a reason the rich
people aren't claiming that land back
it's because it's all flood plain so
when you have torrential rains and this
this these different cycles of weather
patterns that we're seeing that are very
unstable obviously women are going to be
impacted in these mega slums and most
people don't know that that even in
disasters women have a higher rate of
dying from hurricanes from flooding now
in certain areas where you're
economically equal where women can have
an education where women do own property
things like that it's more equal the
male's of females that die but in much
of the world more women die from climate
activity even today than they will in
the future and we know food insecurity
is a breeding ground for sexual
trafficking and this is going to be
another problem so part of my NGO what
we do we improve sanitation we protect
water resources we help girls stay in
school and we end up with compost so you
can amend soil
these are agriculture people you know if
you amend the soil the water you get you
can maintain you can draw down carbon
which is part of what we need to do for
climate change so that's why I'm very
passionate about this how these things
overlap one another an impact one
another but say if a woman is empowered
economically is she a better force of
good is she a stronger force of change
within her community including you know
these agricultural supply chains that
you're talking about but also household
spending and behavior within the society
well women do three quarters of the non
paid work and so the more empowered the
woman is obviously those around her are
and and the safer choices that she gets
to make you know it's very difficult
when when you have no
when you have no standing when your
society will give you know standing
whatsoever you may need to go the doctor
but if somebody doesn't say yeah you can
spend some of our money on you going to
the doctor you're not going it's not
going to happen for you and it's really
really heartbreaking this situation
women are in how do you change that so
through your NGO but how do people the
people need to lobby governments -
people need to lobby their companies to
do more well I have to say like looking
at NGOs since I've been in this sector
since 2010 the first thing I started to
see was all of a sudden business and I'm
going to call BS on this everyone
everyone the aid model started to go -
hey what's the business gonna be how's
this going to be sustainable well when
I'm looking at a woman who has to feed
one of her kids on Monday that one on
Tuesday that one on Wednesday that one
gets fed again on Thursday she doesn't
have money for these things we're using
our our aid money as a country to put
into health care three-quarters of all
hospital beds in Africa are diarrheal
diseases kids are getting sick from
dirty water but we have no sanitation
we're spending the money but we're
spending it in all different places and
and not as well as we could then we're
expecting this lady to somehow have
extra money to pay for clean water by
water and and sanitation it's just not
realistic then I saw the aid world
change to what it is today eight groups
big aid groups all the money is drawing
up and now they're saying governments
you need to do it and yeah it's true
there's been a lot of malfeasance and
governments aren't doing their part but
still at the end of the day I look at
this woman I look at this kid and
somebody's got to help it it is these
are human beings and they're valuable
and they're beautiful human beings I
mean one of our things that we do with
our project we worked at Standing Rock
the Sioux tribe brought us in we worked
with the whyyou tribe in South America
we work with tribes and original
people's around the world that have high
infant mortality rates it's important
that these people survive it is
important that these cultures survive
these traditional original people
survive and you know as the government's
we're also seeing land grabs traditional
people who used to move now when they
leave their ancestral lands being taken
for mining so so many things are coming
all at once on people so are we becoming
more responsible as a world or less
responsible because we talk about there
are conferences like this focusing on a
climate change and on women rights is it
making a difference well I'm glad we're
all talking about it but I think we have
to address it in multiple ways obviously
I think that it's completely unhelpful
that the United States right now is
pulling out of climate change Accords
that we have a president that's in
denial that we have half the country
pretending this is junk science that's
not helpful but I think we need to do a
lot of things and I do think we have to
look at our agricultural practices
because part of it is also mono cropping
depleting our soils not looking at you
know if we're drawing down carbon which
is part of the answer less emissions you
know putting but also improving our
soils because then we could draw down
the carbon and then it goes into the
root system into humus and we can pull
some of it back out I mean I've been
doing some research and it's clear that
gender equality or women when women are
empowered especially in developing
societies it actually has a multiplier
effect on some of these SDGs yeah so do
people realized do again organizations
realize that that's kind of the source
where you need to go if you had support
for your NGO well what we do is often we
work with smaller and large skillet in G
as we work with water aid in South
America and beekeeping woman's group and
then we work with like basket Weaver's
and dancers in in Kenya so we work with
schools and Geo's that have multiple
schools we work with groups that have
at-risk
people were doing a pilot in a mega slum
in Uganda because all of these things
are important and mega slums there's
gonna be I think in the next 40 years
half more than half the world's
population are gonna be living in mega
Slim's you've always advocated women
rights and equal rights where does that
come from
what when did you realize that this was
you know that something needed to change
you know I didn't grow up really hearing
the word feminist that much my friend's
mom did work at a place called a
feminist women's health center so I
heard it but it was sort of like what's
that word what is a feminist I don't
know it wasn't really something I my mom
was very traditional in many ways but I
did see my mom's powerlessness you know
there was a time where my mom and dad
were gonna get divorced and my mom had
breast cancer and at that time and we're
about to revisit that time possibly
after I don't know 27 28 maybe 30 years
of marriage and five kids she said you
know what I can't divorce your dad
because I won't have health care and I
have breast cancer and I'll be
uninsurable and it was like oh my god
you know you were his partner and you
were a big part of his whole life but
society you were invisible the next day
they will drop you and you you've done
nothing your whole life as far as
society is concerned and so that that
was one of my my lessons also I was a
single mom when I was 19 so and I had to
give up job opportunities where where I
where I definitely experienced some what
I felt was unfair kind of expectations
on me as a woman what discrimination or
I I weirdly I had to walk away from to
work experiences because one because I
was pregnant and I didn't know how my
pregnancy would be impacted by worrying
about gaining weight on a movie and also
doing a very physical
like beaten and raped kind of seen I
didn't want to go through that while I
was pregnant so I didn't know if I'd
really have a career and then my next
job after I had my my son this director
just wanted me to sign something saying
I would just be naked and do whatever
you wanted I was like I can't do that I
mean really I'm a professional your
professional your director you know what
you want to see what's the idea here
like can we talk through a scene no I
just want you to sign something yeah I'm
not doing and that was hard because I
really didn't know where I was buying
diapers so it was like all right why do
I feel like you're not dealing with me
like a professional person well now the
last thing I had to be naked in they
break everything down now oh it's
different world now youyou gave an
amazing speech five years ago did the
conversation change when you when you
had that acceptance speech did you get
support that people say gosh I wish I
did that well really scary it was really
scary because I knew it was like this
subconscious thing there your unspoken
thing you're not supposed to be
political but you know I was winning
this award for this woman whose life
could have been really different she was
the primary breadwinner for these kids
and caretaker had she made a full dollar
so I knew I wanted to do that but great
things came of it Salesforce did a
gender audit because to the women from
Salesforce saw that speak its speech and
went into Marc Benioff and said hey are
we getting paid for really he said yeah
I'm sure you guys are are you really
sure well let's do a gender audit great
well they find up surprise three million
dollars you know gender discrepancy and
they fix that then they went back the
next year and did a gender and race
audit up another three million bucks
fixed that that's incredible
and Senator Hanna Beth Jackson she said
I've been presenting this this this bill
for 36 years but once you said that I
threw it on the floor it passed and then
41 other laws passed
States sister bills there's still a long
way to go but business like with
Salesforce doing that he called Marc
Benioff called on all these other
companies they signed up to be gender
partners to do pay audits and to make up
discrepancies and that's a wonderful way
to go and it's an easy thing for you
know he says himself any CEO can get it
done like that I mean really you go to
accounting they it's barely any work for
them to figure it all that so ideally it
should come from companies I think
because it's the right way to treat your
employees and from the employees
pressuring the companies but even
Iceland which has been committed to
equal pay more than any other government
and has had laws on the books for
decades they said at this point if you
you have to do a gender audit and if you
will find a discrepancy we are going to
and you don't fix it in a short period
of time we will penalize you and I think
that's where we have to get to because
many companies don't want to do it did
you get backlash after that speech did
you almost not make that speech well I
got some backlash but I would have not
not made that speech because the I
wanted to help people and I was part of
something where all these activists had
been doing this work forever it wasn't
like I did this no but I just opened the
door for the activists and the leaders
and the law makers to be heard and that
employees to be heard a little more so I
got to be a part of something that's
meaningful to me you testified two weeks
ago the US Congress in support of the
Equal Rights Amendment why do we need to
do that in 2019 hmm what a question well
yes
so the Equal Rights Amendment you know
when the Justice Scalia a recent Supreme
Court justice said certainly the
Constitution doesn't require
discrimination on the basis of sex the
question is whether it prohibits it
doesn't so if you have a Supreme Court
justice like him
they interpret the Constitution from the
time it was written the time it was
written black women were slaves and and
white women were considered the chattel
or property of their husband or their
father so he's not lying when he says
that's how he interprets the
Constitution and will make legal
decisions from his concept of the
Constitution so we're in dangerous
territory when people don't think you're
supposed to have equal rights and we've
seen that happen actually part of the
Violence Against Women Act was struck
down when Christine Bron kala tried to
use it on campus assault rape cases so I
mean when I started to look at all these
different weird laws all 50 states had
untested rape kits hmm is that because
most the victims are women
that's where don't you think there are
no ones budgeting to test evidentiary
infirm a Couture for rape that all these
hospitals don't even know how to collect
evidence and a rape kit even though it's
such a common trauma that people go
through seven states women can be forced
to co-parent with their convicted
rapists we now have new laws passing
just yesterday anti-abortion laws you
know including people who are incest it
and rape and raped I mean there's no
protections in certain states they want
to get this to the Supreme Court they
want to overturn Roe vs. Wade and they
don't want the Equal Rights Amendment to
pass because they're afraid that we give
women more grounds to have rights to
abortion because they would be full
people that's the truth that's what
they're afraid of
is it getting worse in the u.s. at the
same time you have a record number of
female representatives in Congress yeah
and that's wonderful well that very
exciting and we have some very strong
candidates running for a president now
too or women
does that help yes it helps I think it
is helpful what would you change if you
have to change one thing right now in
the US or on how women I don't know if
it was oh boy I don't know one first
that genie thing like you have three
wishes okay one I wish for more wishes
yeah I don't know if they're imagined is
there something so many things I mean I
guess okay in this conversation I would
say you know to deal with all civil
rights in America make everything really
just and fair he's getting it right is
there is there a part of the world is
there someone is there one person that
you look up to well for equal pay I
really like the leadership of Iceland I
mean they're really really committed to
being the first nation on earth that pay
women equally and I think that's a
really important powerful thing have you
ever had to pay for or fight for your
pay or if I've worked away from jobs
weirdly I never really thought of my own
equal pay before I gave that cuz I
always just felt like I'm so lucky I'm
an actor oh my god I'm living the dream
I can't believe it
now for years I'd heard this
subconscious kind of thing well they got
to hire the guy first well there's no
money left because they paid the guy you
know but that was kind of normal like I
had really internalized like that was
just normal the way it is you know I
mean even on recent jobs you know that
was the situation I change now has
something done has anything changed
has anything not even so much I mean not
honestly I like I was on we had a whole
different cast for escape at Dannemora
but then the guy dropped out so the move
the whole thing almost fell apart didn't
matter
that I was the lead and it didn't matter
that I'd won an Oscar didn't matter that
I was already there I still needed to
wait for a guy the guy with and then the
guy got paid twice what I got paid and
I'm not mad at him but I mean it it
doesn't matter if I had a TV shows on 18
million people watching every week right
can you imagine if that was a movie
showing and you had 18 million people
per viewing now how did the biggest box
office movie on earth well not on earth
okay but you know what I'm saying it
would be a huge head so I don't know
who's modulating these things are
deciding what value is it's kind of
crazy but yeah I still feel very lucky
and I feel still feel grateful but have
you ever had a male actress they look by
the way I'm sorry or or you know is it
up to to the guy really weirdly don't
really blame the guys I think it's more
about agents cuz I and I've said that to
my whole agency all you guys need to get
it together
you have internalized this
subconsciously and you have not been
working hard enough for your female
clients I mean you know it happened with
the Michelle Williams situation right he
was paid like fifteen hundred times more
than her right for these reshoots
they're the same agency what's going on
here what is happening here so yeah I
mean I think we're all I know I was
raised with a lot of internalized
misogyny or internalized sort of the way
things are like the status quo was just
a part of my understanding what what
advice do you give to your kids on this
huh you know what I think somebody had
said to me once your she had five kids
she said this one is nothing like this
one so I think you have to be a linguist
to be a parent you know my advice for my
son is totally different than my advice
for my daughter I think not so much for
their gender
although I catch myself you know being
sexist all the time with them but more
who they are as people you know what's
your strength hey to my daughter I'm
like you shouldn't be as hard on
yourself I might say I'm like you need
to be a little harder um put your shark
out what's the best piece of advice
you've ever been given and how to deal
with either inequality or or gender
issues or anything that's just unjust
you know my mom is to say to me all the
time first thing in the morning when you
get up before you get out of bed or do
anything just close your eyes and get
quiet and ask God who is Patricia like
ask who your own self is feel your own
self and the quality of your nature what
is that and I think because my mom kind
of raised me on all of us to kind of be
connected to who we are that guided me
to have my own voice you know so I think
my mom you know was my greatest teacher
put your short kid thank you so much
thank you